hey dr. Berg here in this short video
we're going to talk about Hashimoto's
thyroiditis simplified now Hashimoto's
is a type of a thyroid problem which is
a hypothyroid but it's a different type
it's actually an immune issue problem
and I want to give you some insights
because when you do research on this you
really won't find much about it
so I want to show you something this is
a sipper collection of medical
illustrations endocrinology vol 4 by dr.
Frank nitori's and MD I'm going to show
you on page 84 just going to read
something too and this page is on
something that describes cortisol the
biological actions of cortisol that's
the stress hormone so it's as cortisol
diverts amino acids from the lymph
tissue now the limp tissue is all the
immune tissue so it the cortisol pushes
in protein from that limp tissue so you
don't you don't get as much amino acid
and so we get a marked reduction in size
of your lymph nodes in other words it
causes an atrophy or a shrinkage of your
immune system yeah cortisol will cause
the shrinkage of the immune system and
then this accompanied by a release of
anti-bodies now what does that mean it
means that all those stored antibodies
now are released into the blood so we're
getting a release of these little
antibodies which basically help they're
part of the immune system and then it
says that eventual decrease in overall
antibody production so what happens with
cortisol is you get a lowering of the
entire immune system and the ability to
protect our bodies which then breaks
down the immune barrier and raises
susceptibility to viral and bacterial
infections so now what does all that
mean
it means that there's a huge connection
between stress and the immune deficiency
issues when we get into Hashimoto's or
any autoimmune problem just ask the
person this one question when did it
start and you're going to find it will
always start after some stress event
Allah
of a level-one the divorce job loss an
injury a trauma whatever and all of a
sudden it sets up a weakness within the
adrenal lowering the immune system and
then your body starts attacking itself
so why would your body develop
antibodies to attack itself other than
that whole system is lost control and
it's out of control and that's what this
is it's a your body's has producing
little antibodies against itself and so
it's a self attack and it keeps the
thyroid inflamed so that's what this is
and it's triggered by I believe high
cortisol which is stress and then the
whole thing starts becoming a problem so
now okay so that's that's kind of my
theory on what's going on but now what
can we do about it
well we want to do two things we want to
reduce the inflammation because there's
an itis and some really good things to
do for that to help the immune system is
to take vitamin d3 and by the way that
adrenal thing that cortisol that will
deplete your vitamin D as well so you
want to take a little bit more than you
normally take so take about 10,000 IU's
but make sure you take vitamin k2 with
it I've done videos on this this is very
important you need to take these
together because they work together so
take about 100 micrograms of k2 10,000
IU's of vitamin d3 and then add some cod
liver oil norm about 500 milligrams and
this combination is very
anti-inflammatory so it will actually
help the inflammation piece of it but
there's something else that is out there
that you may want to look into it's a
product by standard process and you're
going to have to find a practitioner
that has it but it's called thyroid
thyrotropin PMG I wrote Rauf in PMG and
the PMG part is really DNA extract of
thyroid gland from my cow or a sheep
whatever so it's a glandular extract but
it's a siphoned out DNA from that so
they take the DNA out and they put it in
tablet it's the news spurt for probably
40 years in the area of alternative
health and so when a person would take
thyrotropin PMG before bed they'd
probably take one it goes into the
stomach and because that DNA is very
similar to our DNA instead of the
thyroid attacking itself it goes what
what the heck is this let's go back over
here and start attacking this thing in
the stomach so it actually never even
leaves the stomach it goes into the
lymphatic system around the stomach and
it kind of just hangs out there and it
it causes a diversion it distracts the
antibodies to attack this decoy and it
leaves the thyroid alone so the guy who
developed this theory is a genius dr.
Royal Lee back in probably 20s and 30s
but this is a really simple way of kind
of taking the immune system and shifting
it over here and leaving the thyroid
alone so we can start to heal so those
are a couple tips in my two cents on the
Hashimoto's thyroiditis